PROFESSOR: Determinism.
And it all begins with photons.
Einstein reluctantly
came up with the idea
that light was made of quanta--
quanta of light called photons.
Now when you think of photons,
we think of a particle.
So everybody knew
that light was a wave.
Maxwell's equations
had been so successful.
Nevertheless,
photoelectric effect--
Planck's work-- all were leading
to the idea that, in some ways,
photons were also particles.
So when you think of a
particle, however, there
is an important difference
between a particle
in the sense of Newton, which
is an object with zero size that
carries energy and
has a precise position
and velocity at any time, and
the quantum mechanical idea
of particle, which is just some
indivisible amount of energy
or momentum that propagates.
So light was made of photons--
packets of energy.
And a photon is a particle--
a quantum mechanical particle.
Not in the sense that maybe
it has position and velocity
determined or it's
a point particle,
but more like a packet
that is indivisible.
You cannot decompose
it in further packets.
So Einstein realized
that for a photon,
the energy was given by h nu.
Where nu is the
frequency of the light
that this photon is
helping build up.
So if you have a
beam of light, you
should think it's
billions of photons.
And according to the
frequency of that light
that is related to
the wavelength--
by the equation frequency
times wavelength
is velocity of light--
you typically know, for
light, the wavelength,
and you know the
frequency, and then
you know the energy of
each of the photons.
The photons have very,
very little energy.
We have very, very
little energy,
but your eyes are very
good detectors of photons.
If you're in a totally
dark room, your eye,
probably, can take as
little as five photons
if they hit your retina.
So it's a pretty good
detector of photons.
Anyway, the thing that
I want to explain here
is what happens if a beam
of light hits a polarizer.
So what is a polarizer?
It's a sheet of plastic
or some material.
It has a preferential direction.
Let me align that preferential
direction with the x-axis,
and that's a polarizer.
And if I send light
that is linearly
polarized along the x-axis,
it all goes through.
If I send light linearly
polarized along the y-axis,
nothing goes through.
It all gets absorbed.
That's what a polarizer
does for a living.
In fact, if you send
light in this direction,
the light that comes out
is identical to the light
that came in.
The frequency doesn't change.
The wavelength doesn't change.
It's the same light,
the same energy.
So far, so good.
Now let's imagine that we send
in light linearly polarized
at some angle alpha.
So we send an electric
field E alpha,
which is E0 cosine alpha x
hat plus E0 sine alpha y hat.
Well, you've studied
electromagnetism,
and you know that this thing,
basically, will come around
and say, OK, you can go
through because you're
aligning the right
direction, but you
are orthogonal to my
preferential direction,
or orthogonal I absorbed,
so this disappears.
So after the polarizer, E is
just E0 cosine alpha x hat.
That's all that is left
after the polarizer.
Well here is something
interesting--
you know that the energy
on electromagnetic field
is proportional to the
magnitude of the electric field
square, that's what it is.
So the magnitude of
this electric field--
if you can notice,
it's the square root
of the sum of the
squares will give you
E0 as the magnitude of
this full electric field.
But this electric field has
magnitude E0 cosine alpha.
So the fraction of power--
fraction of energy through
is cosine alpha squared.
The energy is always
proportional to the square.
So the square of this is E0
squared cosine squared alpha.
And for this one, the
magnitude of it is E0,
so you divide by E0 and cosine
alpha is the right thing.
This is the fraction
of the energy.
If alpha is equal to 0,
you get cosine of 01.
You get all the energy 1.
If alpha is equal to
pi over 2, the light
is polarized along
the y direction,
nothing goes through--
indeed, cosine of pi over 2 is
0, and nothing goes through.
So the fraction of
energy that goes through
is cosine squared alpha.
But now, think what
this means for photons.
What it means for
photons is something
extraordinarily strange.
And so strange that it's
almost unbelievable that we
get so easily in trouble.
Here is this light
beam over here,
and it's made up of photons.
All identical photons,
maybe billions of photons,
but all identical.
And now, think of sending
this light beam over there--
a billion identical photons--
you send them one by one
into the state, and
see what happens.
You know what has to happen,
because classical behavior is
about right.
This fraction of the
photons must go through,
and 1 minus that
must not go through.
You see, it cannot be there
comes a photon and half of it
goes through, because there's
no such thing as half of it.
If there would be
half of it, it would
be half the energy and,
therefore, different color.
And we know that
after a polarizer,
the color doesn't change.
So here is the situation.
You're sending a billion
photons and, say, one-third
has to get through.
But now, the photos
are identical.
How can that happen
in classical physics?
If you send identical photos,
whatever happens to a photon
will happen to all, but the
photon either gets absorbed
or goes through.
And if it gets absorbed,
then all should get absorbed.
And if it goes through,
all should go through
because they are all identical.
And now you have
found a situation
which identical
set of experiments
with identically
prepared objects
sometimes gives you
different results.
It's a debacle.
It's a total disaster.
What seems to have
happened here--
you suddenly have
identical photons,
and sometimes they go
through, and sometimes they
don't go through.
And therefore, you've
lost predictability.
It's so simple to show
that if photons exist,
you lose predictability.
And that's what
drove Einstein crazy.
He knew when he
entered these photons
that he was getting in trouble.
He was going to get in trouble
with classical physics.
So possible ways out--
people speculate about it--
people said, well, yes,
the photos are identical,
but the polarizer
has substructure.
If it hits in this interatomic
part, it goes through,
and in that interatomic
part, it doesn't go through.
People did experiments
many times.
It's not true.
The polarizer is like that.
And then came a more
outrageous proposition
by Einstein and others--
that there are hidden variables.
You think the photons
are identical,
but a photon has a hidden
variable-- a property
you don't know about.
If you knew that property
about the photon,
you would be able to
tell if it goes through
or it doesn't go through.
But you don't know it,
so that's why you're
stuck with probabilities.
It's because the quantum
theory is not complete.
There are hidden variables.
And once you put the
hidden variables,
you'll discover the photon
has more something inside it,
and they are not the same,
even though they look the same.
And that's a hidden
variable theory.
And it sounds so philosophical
that you would think, well,
if you don't know about
them, but they are there,
these properties, how could
you ever know they are there?
And the great progress of John
Bell with the Bell inequalities
is that he demonstrated that
that would not fix the problem.
Quantum mechanics cannot be
made deterministic with hidden
variables.
It was an unbelievable result--
the result of John Bell.
So that's something we will
advance towards in this course
but not quite get there.
805 discusses this
subject in detail.
So at the end of the day,
we've lost determinism.
We can only predict
probabilities.
So photons either
gets through or not,
and can only predict
probabilities.
Now we write, in classical
physics, a beam like that.
But how do we write the
wave function of a photon?
Well, this is quite interesting.
We think of states of a
particle as wave functions.
And I will call them,
sometimes, states;
I will call them,
sometimes, wave functions;
and I sometimes will
call them vectors.
Why vector?
Because the main thing
you do with vectors
is adding them or multiplying
them by numbers to scale them.
And that's exactly what you
can do with a linear equation.
So that's why people think
of states, or wave functions,
as vectors.
And Dirac invented
a notation in which
to describe a photon
polarized in the x direction,
you would simply write
something like this.
Photon colon x and this object--
you think of it as some
vector or wave function,
and it represents a
photon in the x direction.
And we're not saying yet
what kind of vector this is,
but it's some sort of vector.
It's not just a symbol,
it represents a vector.
And that's a possible state.
This is a photon
polarized along x.
And you can also
have, if you wish,
a photon polarized along y.
And linearity means that
if those photos can exist,
the superposition can exist.
So there can exist a state
called cos alpha photon x
plus sine alpha photon y,
in which I've superposed
one state with another--
created a sum-- and this I
call the photon state polarized
in the alpha direction.
So this is how, in quantum
mechanics, you think of this--
photons-- we will elaborate that
and compare with this equation.
It's kind of interesting.
What you lose here is this ease.
There's no ease there
because it's one photon.
When you have a
big electric field,
I don't know how many
photons there are.
I would have to calculate
the energy of this beam
and find the frequency
that I didn't specify,
and see how many photons.
But each photon in this
beam quantum mechanically
can be represented as
this superposition.
And we'll talk more about
this superposition now
because our next subject
is superpositions
and how unusual they are.
Well the hidden
variable explanation
failed because Bell
was very clever,
and he noted that
you could design
an experiment in which
the hidden variables would
imply that some measurements
would satisfy an inequality.
If the existed hidden
variables and the world
was after all classical,
the results of experiments
would satisfy a Bell inequality.
And then a few years
later, the technology
was good enough that
people could test the Bell
inequality with an experiment,
and they figured out
it didn't hold.
So the hidden variables
lead to Bell inequalities
that are experimentally
shown not to hold.
And we will touch
a little bit on it
when we get to untangle them.
After the polarizer, the photon
is in the state photon x.
It's always polarized
along the x direction,
so it's kind of similar that
this doesn't go through.
This goes through, but
at the end of the day,
as we will explain very
soon, the cosine alpha
is not relevant here.
When it goes through, the
whole photon goes through.
So there's no need
for a cosine alpha.
So that's what goes
out of the polarizer.